our culture strongly inclines us to the
view that genuine love must involve
complete acceptance of another person in
that good and especially in s somewhat
bad science
in moments of fury with our partners we
may be tempted to dismiss their
complaints against us with the cry just
love me as I am but in truth none of us
should want to remain exactly as we are
in love and therefore none of us should
to strongly want another person to love
as opposed to tolerate or simply forgive
what is warped within us genuine love
might be defined as gently and kindly
helping someone to become the best
version of themselves not accepting
themselves precisely as they are it
isn't a betrayal of love for someone to
try to help us to evolve to teach us to
become better people in fact it may be
the highest proof of genuine commitment
unfortunately under the sway of a
romantic ideology that makes a
suspicious of emotional education most
of us end up being terrible teachers and
equally terrible students in
relationships we don't accept the
legitimacy let alone the nobility of
others desire to teach us and we can't
acknowledge areas where we might need to
be taught we rebel against the very
structure of a lover's education that
would enable criticism to be molded into
sensible sounding lessons and to be
heard as caring attempts to reject the
more troublesome aspects of our
personalities at the first sign that the
other person is adopting a teacher Lee
tone we tend to assume that we're being
attacked and betrayed and therefore we
close our ears to the instruction
reacting with sarcasm and aggression to
the teacher our stance is deeply
understandable to the mother
everything about her tiny infant is
delightful
they wouldn't change even the smallest
thing their baby is perfect just as it
is our idea of love has taken this kind
of attitude very much to heart it's what
we grow up thinking that love is
supposed to be like the suggestion that
another person could want us to change
grow or improve is taken as an insult to
love the problem is the mother never in
fact loved us just as we were she hoped
we would keep growing up and the need to
keep growing up is still there our
bodies may be fully formed but our
psyches always have some growing up
still to do
we should never hold it against our
lovers if they don't love us just as we
are they're doing something far more
generous wanting us to be a little
better if you want to learn more about
love try our book on how to find love
which explains why we have the types we
do and how our early experiences give us
scripts of how and whom we love